إذا كان هدفك هو خلق عادة ، فإن ما
تهدف إليه حقًا هو وضع
سلوك على الطيار الآلي ، فإن
أحد المفاهيم الخاطئة الشائعة حول العادات هو
أنك تريد حقًا أن تكون
متسقًا للغاية في الوقت والمكان المحددين
للتنفيذ وفي الواقع بعض
أبحاثي  يُظهر أنه من المهم إذا كنت
ترغب في بناء عادة أن تكون أكثر
مرونة قليلاً من ذلك ، فقال إنك تريد بناء
عادة للتمرين إذا كانت دائمًا في التاسعة صباحًا
جيدًا ماذا يحدث عندما تأتي حافلة أطفالك
متأخرة وليس لديك وقت
للوصول  صالة الألعاب الرياضية في الساعة 9 صباحًا ،
ترفع يديك وتقول إنني لا أستطيع فعل
ذلك ، لكن إذا كنت قد اكتسبت عادة أكثر مرونة
لأنك أحيانًا تذهب إلى
صالة الألعاب الرياضية في الساعة 9 صباحًا وعندما لا يكون ذلك مجديًا ،  في
الخامسة مساءً ، ستكون أكثر
ميلًا للالتزام بالعادة بغض
النظر عن السبب ، من المهم أن تكون مرنًا ليس فقط
أنه من المقبول الوقوع في خطوات خاطئة
عندما تحاول متابعة الأهداف ، فهذا أمر
طبيعي ولكن إذا كان لديك عقلية النمو
وترى أن شيئًا ما لا يسير على
ما يرام وتخبر نفسك ، ما الذي
يمكنني أن أتعلمه من أن يكون لديك
عقلية نمو عندما تنظر إلى الفشل
كفرصة للتعلم بدلاً من
تشخيص عدم قدرتك ،
ترى في الواقع نتائج أفضل بكثير
عقلية النمو هي مفتاح الإنجاز
لأنها تقودك إلى انتقاء نفسك
والاستمرار في العمل والقيام بعمل أفضل في كل مرة
تحاول فيها تحقيق
هدفك ،
فكيف تبني هذه العادات بشكل جيد
هو في الواقع تكرار بسيط
لسلوك يبني عادات  في كثير من
الأحيان تفعل ذلك كلما بدأت
تشعر وكأنها طبيعة ثانية وتذهب إلى
الطيار الآلي